Hàng hàng không quốc tế lắm thành đồng này được tổ chức dữ liệu hàng không OIG.
Rự báo có thể gián nhập nhóm xanh bay phục vụ 1 chí ở hành khách 1 năm trong vào 1 năm tới cùng với các xíu cảm đa hí thành tại cho á.
Dự bó này được OIG, tổ chức theo dõi và thông cây dữ liệu hàng không quốc tế đưa ra trong bà cao mọi nhất có tin,
sự chỗi dạy của các xíu cảm hàng không.
Càng hàng không quốc tế lắm thành đường xây dựng tại tình đồng này trên dễ tích khoảng 5 nghỉ hát ta,
bởi tổ nấu tư hơi 3,3 bà bà bà bà xây đoạn.
Hẹn dự á năng trong dạy đoạn bột dự kiến các bạn hòn thành vào cuối năm này.
Ở dạy đoạn này, lắm thành có công sốt phục vụ 2.5 chíu được thành khách vào 1.5 chíu tấn hạn ngoài 1 năm.
Dạy đoạn 2 dự kiến hòn thành vào năm ngày 1,3 bà 1 năm.
Bộ xung tế 1 ca hình khách và 1 đường mắm mới, năng tổng công xuất lên 5 chíu khách vào 1.5 chíu tấn hạn ngoài 1 năm.
Dạy đoạn 4 cùng, dự kiến hòn thành vào khoảng 5,3 gỉ hông 3 bà bà 1 năm.
Hành ín không trong 1 người sẽ đưa tổng công xuất của lắm thành lên 1 trăm chíu khách và 5 chíu tấn hạn ngoài 1 năm.
Ở dưới nhận định, các chính phủ chua đang xem việc phát triển các chung tâm hạn không là độc lực quan trọng.
Để tụng đầy đồ tư trăm vào ngoài nước đồng thời, tích câu dú liệt và tạo bị tạm.
Quả chính này được khổ trợ bởi tóc đủ tăng trực kính tế nhàng tăng lấp trung lưu mở giộm và đủ thiếu hoa mạnh mẽ.